so i started off you know as a christian
going to church i never believed that
jesus was like god we never i never
believed in treating the trinities you
have to go to detention after that
not actually unsound doesn't make any
sense so we came from a baptist family
it's a sort of radical
it's a radical way of turning off your
brain categorical confirmation meaning
that you see the heavens you see the
earth you recognize that this has a
creator i'm going to confirm that
i'm going to confirm it what's going on
in the world today and islam has the
answers
we got a special special show for you
live
here in pompano beach
pompano beach florida florida at the
islamic center of south florida and my
next guest
imam sheikh derek
pete graduated from the world islamic
sciences amman jordan he focuses on
teaching islam as the religion which
reinforces
universally shared values such as
respecting one's neighbor spreading
compassion and desiring for others what
we desire for ourselves
he is proud to be part of the diverse
religious landscape in the south florida
area he enjoys spearheading interfaith
efforts serving the community and
revolutionizing the current discourse
on faith in america he has a passion for
erasing stereotypes bigotry and false
narratives and he's my guest here on the
dean show assalamu alaikum peace be with
you
how are you doing
are you the new imam here you've been
here for some time well i'm from the
community but um we just joined these i
just joined the center here about two
weeks ago
now how does that that is unimaginable
for some people i mean you
accept islam and not only do you accept
islam
but you start making a difference in
humanity because you're following islam
and then you end up
going to study islam and you become an
imam
let's start with those early years
yeah so i guess it starts started when i
was about
15 years old thinking about myself and
my
yes
the world around me trying to understand
myself
you know my position in the world what's
my purpose what should i be doing
so i started off you know as a christian
going to church um
you know
i guess being attached to the bible
wanting to understand it wanted to
understand wanting to know god
um but feeling that there was something
missing
feeling like there was something else
for me to achieve or something else that
i needed inside
so i then started the journey read the
autobiography of
malcolm x
and um you know was researching
different religions as well
um i think you know yes i think in
conversion it's like a process and then
you have certain uh like milestones or
landmarks in your you know the
conversion journey one of the major
landmarks i guess uh
i was sitting in my history class in
10th grade
and
the teacher
she we're going over on the different
world religions and we spoke about
hinduism
so about buddhism
judaism then christianity and then
we got to islam
you know so i was really really
interested at that time really to see
like an academic presentation of what
the religion was so i read a head in the
book while she was talking so i read
ahead you know who is allah the five
pillars or the pillars of iman what the
muslims believe
so in reading this you know i was just
like
startled taken aback even and uh you
know there's certain you know in the
theology or in the the arabic
the the word um
for what i'm going to describe it's
called in
law basically where allah inspires you
to say something when it's besides
yourself you may just have some words to
say you don't know where that come from
so i'm sitting there in class i raise my
hand teacher calls on me and then i say
if this is what islam is
why isn't everybody muslim
this is really deep man
from allah because
i'm full class yeah
this is what islam teaches why isn't and
you're not a muslim at the time
so you know she explained that did you
have to go to detention accident
no she was nice she was nice really good
teacher
so uh she said well everybody has their
own culture their own background
religion
gave that sort of explanation it wasn't
really satisfactory for me because i
kept on researching i guess the next big
step was me visiting my family in new
york
some muslim family there
that's how i saw i guess islam lived
islam you know really
in a human way i want to stress that you
know islam is something that's human
it's the dino
it's the religion of primordiality the
original of humanity and it comes to
reaffirm humanity and it's a really
important lesson for
us as muslims nowadays that we cannot
really be good muslims without being
good human beings right
um so that's what i saw in new york
islam just on the street islam people
mixing it up
you know these really had a profound
impact on me
so that was the next major step i wasn't
muslim yet at that time but my um a
family member gave me um some books and
then i i took the books home read them
and alhamdulillah decided that islam was
really the way forward for me
yeah so um
you
touched upon something that really
reminded me of a little bit about my
journey when i started to also hit the
books and i started to study and see all
these things in the quran like the tohi
the pure monotheism you know the things
that the quran mentioned islam mentions
and the life of prophet muhammad and i
was also like if i just show this to
people they're going to end up accepting
this i was thinking the same thing but
you know we're a little naive in the
beginning huh i think so you know you
expect
because i think at that point you don't
recognize that allah he has a plan and
allah is really the guider yeah and
allah you know basically he knows where
your heart is and he also knows where
other people's hearts are
and um yeah and allow guide who who who
he wills so that you know to the extent
that you know it's really there's this
dawah to accept islam you have allah has
to call you to the religion first it's
an invitation from allah really
sometimes we forget that that we are
muslim by allah's grace we think it's
something that we did or this series of
hands series of events cause and effect
no there's no cause and effect there
it's a lost guidance right so let's go
from the classroom what happens give us
some other highlights or some other
parts of the story this is an amazing
one so now you're how old at that time
so i was uh 15 at this 15. yeah let's go
on continue with the journey so
it
became muslim december 2003 our brother
mirzad looking on right now i remember
yeah he was there my shahada
alhamdulillah
so um that was it was a center close to
about 20 minutes from here a center of
islamic
society of south florida i think that's
an ifsf islamic foundation of south
florida i took my shahada there
yeah and you know the story leading up
to that shahada because i wanted to
become muslim at that time but i
couldn't find any people didn't really
know anyone so i'm in class uh one time
this was a english class and the brother
brother musa some of his nephews are
here right now actually hope they're
listening and paying attention to the
story
so
musa he's there and the kalashnik is
explaining what's the
what the bible is in the muslim
perspective on the bible to a
particular a girl and i heard what he
was saying so i now took the opportunity
to sign about it and say so you're
muslim he's like i kind of had an
inkling i kind of knew this is my time
now to kind of
i guess
just i guess to um
you know just to tell him that i'm
interested in as well right in the
religion so i tell him you know you know
so he's telling her about his
about islam about the perspective on the
bible and i said you know so i'm one of
those two you're talking about i'm one
of these people too
right so he says you're kidding you're
kidding me and i'm like no i want to
convert
so you know he takes my number
um
that's
winter break i accept sept except islam
alhamdulillah
then after that
you know hamlet finished up high school
you know in the
the in piper high school hamlet
then went on to the university of
florida
got the opportunity to study journalism
and also arabic language alhamdulillah
throughout that time though i always had
my mind on on islam wanting to study the
religion further wanting to study you
know further my skills in the arabic
language um in graduating you know that
was really like a turning point
um because i never really saw i guess a
way to go study islam overseas i thought
maybe okay i'll go for six months you
know six months maybe in egypt or you
know summer in egypt or something like
this
then out of nowhere you know
subhanallah
there's there was an imam that was um at
that message
he was there and we mixed it up a bit we
talked and he was like you know you know
what do you think about studying islam
full-time overseas i'm like how can i do
that is that going we'll have you doing
some khutbas you know we're gonna we're
gonna hook you up
right so i'm like okay we'll see what he
what he has in store
um so he effectively connected me with
um islamic islamic american university
gave me a scholarship to study arabic
initially in egypt then i transferred to
jordan
and you know it's been a it's been a
journey since then life-altering really
alhamdulillah then um
came back to the united states 2007
you know transitioned to phoenix arizona
worked on an islamic school project out
there
um you know met really really um you
know some leading
movers and shakers in the united states
people from zaytuna rami hansul
got to spend some time with him and you
know you know be tutored under him
alhamdulillah and then came back to
florida spent some time in fort pierce
uh florida kind of an underserved
community there in
central florida and um now since
2021 been back in the back in the hood
what was your belief
about jesus at that time
before before with that statement that
you said at the in the class in the
classroom what was your belief about
jesus at that time and then maybe you
know five ten years before you accepted
islam so it's funny you asked that
because i never believed that jesus was
like god we never i never believed in
treating the trinity something did you
go to church i did
was that taught in your church it was
but it's not something i ever accepted
you didn't accept it even though the
pastor the preacher yeah he was
preaching john what yeah you know for
their three their record in heaven the
father the son right he's you heard
these uh well we would hear that you'd
hear the theology the doctrine but it's
just
to me it never made sense to my my heart
couldn't accept it
right so my particular belief that jesus
was that you know the son but as far as
him being god no that's that's uh
doesn't doesn't make any sense what was
your reasoning behind that or did your
fit your innate nature just
push that away but um it just it's um
intellectually unsound doesn't make any
sense intellectually unsound yeah and i
think uh my whole thing was that
religion
god creates us he's gonna give us a
religion
that
is um in tune and in congruence with our
um with with logic it's gonna make sense
allah created you and he then sends a
religion that's gonna
um correlate or be in in tune with what
you feel inside and how you see the
world and with um you know it's gonna
it's gonna make sense effective it's
gonna be one plus one equals two it's
not gonna be you know one plus one plus
one equals one no that doesn't work in
any mathematicals
you know now did you end up going back
to have any discussions with any of your
uh people of the community church to ask
you know what's the purpose of life were
you thinking about the purpose of life
definitely so i would um you know i'd
speak to
like my mom i'd speak to about um you
know
uh but the thing is so we came from a
baptist family
and in our sort of
pers their persuasion they're all my
they're they're my family alhamdulillah
but they
were of a persuasion that you don't ask
these sorts of questions you don't ask
no basically you accept you know it's a
it's a sort of radical
it's a radical way of turning off your
brain that's what i thought of it as and
it's just um to me i'd call it
intellectual oppression it's like
intellectual intellectual depression
like uh just you shut your brain off
right
and um you don't ask any questions they
call they have a term for it maybe some
if some people are from the caribbean
they know this term they'd say it's
flying in god's face
when you have a question
you know so basically if
if you if you have this sort of question
that means you you have like a like a
bad manners with god
having questions about um you know
theology but if you contrast that with
islam it's kind of the opposite no
definitely
that basically in islam your belief is
actually something that is um it needs
to be in in
your subhanallah even the word eman
it's a bad translation to translate it
as a belief
right iman is it's really what iman
means how the scholars they define iman
it's like basically it's categorical
confirmation categorical confirmation
meaning that you see the heavens you see
the earth you recognize that this has a
creator i'm going to confirm that
i'm going to confirm it it's not like
okay i'll make a leap of faith
that's not faith in islam that's not
iman that's something else
maybe that's a christian conception
islamic conception the islamic
conception is that you see the heavens
you see the earth you see the miracle
inside yourself and you confirm
right so definitely um
what do you tell some of the youth who
come to you and they're saying they go
to university they're good before they
get to university yeah and then they
come back saying i'm having a crisis of
faith have you heard this
oh absolutely you know this is one of
the projects that we have is to really
prepare the youth to deal with some of
those uh pressures of the university
some of that that adversity that they're
going to face whether in the philosophy
of
philosophy class science class learning
about evolution learning about the
different isms that are out there and
the sort of competing ideas that compete
with la ilaha
because we don't recognize that
something it's an entire world view
effectively so it's a shape that the way
that you fit you view the world what you
believe and how you understand it right
so you then have these different
ideologies and worldviews that compete
in the university setting so one of the
things that we plan to do here at the
center is prepare our youth to handle
those challenges not only that to handle
them but also to conquer those
challenges right so not only equip them
to defend themselves but also to go i
mean want to use the best words here but
go on the offensive right go on the
offensive and call to this religion
properly
now so when you had your first exposure
to islam now what was it that separated
islam from the man-made religions that
you confirmed like hold on you know
there's evidence behind this it's just
not blind faith i'm just not jumping
into this blindly
yeah so one of the things that um one of
the um i guess
things that i faced early on as a muslim
it's that okay muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam claimed to be a prophet
and he claims that he is
in a line of prophets coming from moses
uh you know
jesus and that he is the final prophet
so he makes this claim
i thought it's uh you know i need to
confirm or either deny whether that
claim is true or not
right so
effectively i had to figure out whether
that was true or not i had to re do my
research and the fact it came back that
muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam is
supported by too many different miracles
whether that's the quran or his ability
to transform the arabian peninsula
and that he calls and he
he calls for a religion that confirms
everything that comes before it
christianity judaism and so on and so
forth and
so
yeah so
for me it just made it just
what was rather clear
of course um there was i guess another
challenge that i had it came as it
concerns the nation of islam
and their position and then i had to
sort of research that and say okay is
that claim true is elijah muhammad was
he a prophet and you know that can um
i think anybody who does the research
can see you know
the veracity of that claim or the lack
thereof right
so you know with with um what i saw in
the religion and what muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam called to
came very very clear very clear
lucid and you know allah says if this
quran for example was from other than
allah you would find so much difference
in it you would find
instability but that's not we find in
the quran we find it's clear message
stability
so you spoke about
trying to prepare the youth to overcome
their adversities
what are some of like the common
barriers that you see
in trying to help that and how do you
overcome that
oh subhanallah
about that one some of the common
barriers and immediate barriers is we
don't
recognize the grandeur of our faith
we don't recognize the grandeur prophet
muhammad
primary thing so we see you know we see
like the west and the western academy we
see
the western philosophy it's something so
great big grand and our religion is kind
of small our our prophet salallahu we
see him as being
his da'wah being insufficient to handle
the challenges of the of the day right
so this is probably one of the primary
barriers that we have we call it
inferiority complex we think our
religion doesn't have what it takes
right of course that's because we are
divorced from our heritage as muslims we
are divorced from our history we are
divorced from our turof
right our scholastic heritage
unfortunately but this is what
colonialism did to us
so we can then you know after talking
about the inferiority complex i guess
the next logical step is to talk about
colonialism and how that gave us an
inferiority complex right
so um
studying history we got to know our
history we got to know our heritage you
know got to know where we're coming from
um
so uh you know these a lot of
so much to be said here so much to be
said subhanallah so colonialism that's a
primary uh topic that i focus on uh
because we as muslims basically we've
pushed out the physical colonialists but
we haven't pushed out the spiritual one
meaning to say that we've been maybe we
pushed back against physical colonialism
but in terms of
rectifying what the colonialism
colonialists did to us internally we
haven't we haven't dealt with that yet i
haven't come to terms with that yet we
haven't taken stock of that yet we
haven't healed from that yet
um
so there's a lot and i probably would
use that word more than any other word
healing from these things because
there's been trauma spiritual trauma you
know along with physical trauma but uh
you know intellectual trauma
you know we we have a term sometimes i
use these terms so i try to define them
but these are important terms that we we
should know uh like for example the
colonialists one of the things that they
would do they would do something we can
call epistemicide
epistemicide that means basically they
take your history and they pretty much
erase it so ways that you used to
understand you used to know used to be
balanced they take it basically warp it
erase it basically they and they also
want to tell you that your religion is
no longer adequate so don't believe it
it's not going to help you anymore
you know you can't reach the okay you
may see the grand buildings and the
grand
uh things of the past the edifice of the
edifice of the past but that's
old-fashioned
you can't regain that heritage or that
honor anymore this lie
right so it's we caught we can call it
um
it's a sort it's a spiritual warfare
that's that's just to say it's straight
exactly what it is
go ahead i'll get to you next
time
i'm not sure if you remember me of
course i remember you yeah i uh i went
with you back to the time when i picked
you up yes to pray aisha yeah yeah i was
praying for you
and then today i look at you masha allah
it has been over maybe 15 years or so
subhanallah uh make me may allah bless
you i'm very proud of you
thank you very much
i would like to get your take and and
some words from you and advice
inshaallah for do you see this do you
share with me and what i've been seeing
is that there's like a shift for example
those you know born and raised with
islam among them
our youth
tend to be drifting far far from islam
and yet alhamdulillah
people from you know non-muslim
backgrounds whether it be atheism
christianity even judaism hinduism
you know staunch secularism whatever it
may be alhamdulillah it's like as if
allah is just picking people
and granting
them is it
what
what my fear is is that if is it allah
taking it away from people who don't
appreciate it
you know don't realize what they have
and it's like a almost like a limited
seating type of thing limited
availability if you don't appreciate it
hand it off to somebody who will and
carry it off is is that what's happening
or
you know this is something that my heart
aches constantly because of this
alhamdulillah you know
i love islam i'm
something i'm most grateful for in my
life
i'm not a muslim revert but i feel like
i have one foot in that in that sense
but subhanallah i mean help me my
brother you have you know alhamdulillah
great knowledge and insight on this you
know so allah answers that question in
the quran and also throughout islamic
history
all right so that will this the quranic
answer is that that um if the people and
i'm forgetting the arabic so forgive me
so i'll just
you know translate into the english that
if a people turn away from the faith
then allah will bring a people you know
in other people who allah loves and they
love allah you know so that's that's the
direct answer right there in the quran
that if our hearts aren't oriented
towards our creator oriented towards the
rasulallah
then allah will replace us you know
that's that's the the fact of the matter
and that goes for everyone that we have
to keep our hearts connected to the
creator but to see through the
guise and the
the um tricks of shaitaan we have to see
through that right
and not fall for not get caught up in
the game
right and then you know that's the
quranic answer then islamic history we
can see that um
you know some of the orientalists or the
scholars that they study islam
they talk about islam on the edge or
islam and how
people will come from the edges and then
come into this come into the center and
effectively revive the religion this is
what you have for example with the
mongols who come and then the turks who
come and effectively revive the faith
and bring islam to um you know the
really the the heights
uh civilizational heights so you know
it's it's it's a
so but the the so that's that's a
reality of the affair that this that's a
process that you mentioned but islam you
know it's nobody's property
it's not it's not a tribal affair it's
not your color it's not about your
national origin it's about where your
heart is
and we can't probably can't repeat that
too much it's about where your heart is
your is your heart connected with allah
or is it somewhere else and of course
getting our hearts connected to allah
it's a process but we want to always do
the taubah that we make mistakes but we
want to always be the people the best of
those who make mistakes of course the
tawabun the people who do the tawba do
the isthakar are in a constant state of
struggle with themselves right what we
call the jihad
this is a grand struggle struggling
against ourselves struggling to see past
the you know the brother abu bakr may
allah bless him uh talked about you know
in his book here which i'm really
looking forward to reading you know um
he talks about social engineering
and how we as a people we're being
worked on
we're being the word is called
subjectified being taught to think
you're being taught to
we're being turned into animals
basically
that people are being turned into
animals you just eat sleep
cell phone and then go to sleep wake up
do the same thing again being turned
into animals just consumers
and we have to be keenly aware of where
we are
in this in our context or to be keenly
aware of this
you know um
and that you know if we don't protect
our faith there are things to really
block your faith out because shaytan and
those who follow him want you to be an
animal they can manipulate you
they can lead you straight off the cliff
and take do what they want with you and
we have to be keenly aware of that you
have to basically focus on this
we ask allah for protection we ask allah
for tawfiq we ask allah for his mercy
for our shortcomings and our sins
we've got another question right here go
ahead brother sangam so
going in line with what you said with
being subjectified and in regards to
engineering you said that there's a good
way to protect we have to
strengthen our iman and strengthen our
community but what would you say would
be as somebody who's come into the
community at a very young age and
establish yourself in alhamdulillah a
very good position what would you say
would be the best way for us to reach
out to
young kids just like you are people just
like you who are looking for this sort
of comfort
but you know with times changing the
landscape is a little bit different for
discovery and um and acceptance so what
would be
your sort of methods to anybody who is
having
looking for some answers that you yeah
two immediate things
we have to take up stock of where we are
not only physically but spiritually like
what's influencing us what what have we
learned since for example grade school
do we know that the the schooling that
we have gone through it has a particular
pedagogy it has a particular
um
philosophy that underpins it and mind
you that philosophy is not it's not
islam it's something else
what have we been what have we imbibed
since the earliest ages what are the
toxins the poisons that we've taken in
where to take stock of that this is one
take stock of it understand it take
stock of it it's not too hard right
if you insha'allah if you want to join
some of the programs that we're planning
here you can we'll inshallah flesh it
out put it on display make diagrams
break it down
right so taking stock of that of where
we are what has influenced us what has
made us think a particular way right
because of you know the the uh the
educational system which none of it's
not all of it's bad but some of it's
definitely bad
at the you know evolution idea that we
come from apes or big bang that things
can come out of nothing this is it's
really some dark stuff
so taking stock of that and looking to
counteract it and then learning our
faith properly and learning our faith in
a manner that is at a
similar level or a higher level than
what we study at
um in high school and university because
right now what we're doing basically as
muslims is we uh we study the highest
sciences philosophy physics engineering
et cetera et cetera then we suffice
ourselves with the sunday school level
education of islam doesn't make any
sense
doesn't make any sense so you're
studying at the highest levels but then
you see your religion as being something
ah you know sunday school if sunday
school at all or maybe i read a book
every you know once a year
that doesn't work like this it's not the
religion is something that is engaging
it's something that has the everything
that we need to
be successful and we also have to give
some effort in studying the faith
to give some effort into studying and
counteracting
you know what's going on in the world
today and islam has the answers
our faith has the answers but it does
require some effort and some dedication
right so i'd say um
without going into too many details one
of the things that we have to do we have
to study islam properly
and you know and know the historical no
get back to functional islam living
religion
right and and
yeah
there's only so much i can say right now
with you know oh i thank you guys for
coming out here thank you brothers for
traveling the long distance to be here
with us
i hope to see you back soon inshallah
soon very soon thank you thank you
okay last question
my brother if you could uh
tell us
adults and and and teenagers
in this country how do we stay focused
on our path to allah
with everything that's
that's on the table in this country
every all these distractions how do we
stay focused
alike like for
for both
teenagers again and adults because i
think everyone is facing this problem oh
yeah so um we have to know that religion
is a means of us becoming focused
that religion is a means of what they
call mindfulness right
it's a means for that so what i'm saying
is we have to recognize that the
religion
is a means
of achieving and that we have the
ability to achieve the religion it's
just a matter of unlocking it
right and of course that requires study
and explanation but to keep it brief
that islam we have even like for example
we have hadith jibril in hadith jibril
what you basically have in that hadith
is the religion
it's basically summarized
right so you have the islam which is
basically and i'm i'm making a logical
jump here because i don't have time but
islam is your physical regulation how
you regulate yourself physically the
five daily prayers is the brother
walker talked about and how that plays a
role in just shaping the human being's
life and keeping him on track keeping
him focused regulating him right then
you have the fasting and so on and so
forth right so it's your physical
regulation then you have your and we're
pretty good at that often right the
physical regulation the pillars of islam
who are not so good with are the pillars
of iman
iman and really understanding that a
deeper level
right eman what does that really mean
what is your worldview mean and what
what should that
what purpose does that give you what
meaning does that give you what how does
that service you how does that serve you
help you assist you right so that's uh
you're basically your intellectual
regulation then you have ihsan and of
course we say would say that islam and
iman lead to ihsan which is basically so
they are muslim they allow you to
achieve equilibrium or peace or to
worship allah as if you can see him
through this sort of dynamic regulation
regulating the physical and also the
spiritual aspects of the human being we
can then gain stability and achieve even
more than that
right um not so
basically i've been listening to
everyone's answers here and
i'm gonna try to put it more and of a
uh accurate description of what they're
trying to save what um you know what he
i'm trying to piggyback off of him and
multiple individuals here i feel like as
a born muslim i was actually having a
conversation with my friend the other
day or yeah yesterday actually as a born
muslim is that
we
tend to believe on an autopilot mode
where compared to converts they they
went out did their research they
came to a conclusion that this is the
right religion based off all the
knowledge based off all base based off
all the meditation and seclusion that
they've done
so i feel like the problem with the not
not even just the youth but muslims as a
whole the ummah is that we
are just born or taught to believe but
not taught exactly how to believe per se
yes there is the knowledge and that is
definitely the best way to go about the
sunnah
but i feel like we
as a whole
uh
it's hard to practice that belief where
the converts it's they're more firm in
their belief i don't know if i'm making
sense right now but
um so basically my question is what
advice do you have for
born muslims to really strengthen their
tawakkal and their and their belief in
allah
yeah you know
it'll be basically uh at the
to put it simply
you know study the faith
connect yourself to the messenger you
know be a part of the movement
right study islam properly and then
apply it properly you know there are
three stages of datwa just to keep it
really really simple and straightforward
first you learn from qualified
scholarship right and really it's just
simple it's very very simple right you
learn from qualified scholarship
that we can have a discussion after you
know about you know what that looks like
qualified scholarship though
um and then you apply that thing you
apply it then you call to it these three
things it's like it's it's like 100 you
can't miss you do that you're going to
see the effects of the religion on your
life period it's just just that simple
this islam was designed
to
be functional and if we approach it the
right way it will function it'll be
it'll function for anybody
it's like the um
it's the you know allah says
basically that allah descends in the
quran that which is a shifa a cure for
that which is in the hearts and it's a
rahmah and it's a hudan a guidance for
the believers right so it's in the quran
it's built into the religion that you
have this uh ability to
for the human being to transform himself
right um so it's uh it's these three
steps you know learning from qualified
scholarship applying it that's why for
example we teach on the saturday school
here one of the things that we uh do
every time we finish we have all the
kids recite suit lasso for example apply
what you learn even if it's like with
two raka'at go pray right if you study a
darce okay let me see how i can apply
what i just learned that you have a
praxis
a a practical application of what you've
just studied
then you go out to call to it
maybe teaching at a sunday school or you
teaching you know talking to your
friends about it even if it's one small
thing
deliver on my behalf convey on my my
behalf it's even if it's only one ayah
from the quran who can't do that right
so but if you do that
miracles start to happen
miracles start to happen is that real
right it transformed the sahaba there
was a man who um his name was ziad ibn
abi
he basically is a long time ago this is
he was a governor who went to iraq
the people of iraq were giving trouble
back then
causing mischief he stood up he told
them that you should know that there's
nothing that's going to
fix the latter part of this ummah ummah
other than what fixed the first part of
it this this prophetic religion this
this dynamic mode of regulation and then
you know uh um
um you know achievement
being excellent right being beautiful
you know another um
a narration uh uh
i'm trying to remember the um the
sahabi's name
or rabbi rabi ahmed he goes to the the
the
khasros and uh kasiros of the persian
king says what do you want
right um
he says to him we've come to take you
from the
dunya the constrictedness of the dunya
we've come to take you to the sa'ate
dunya
i'm gonna take you from the
constrictedness of this dunya false
god's false perspectives all sorts of
falsehoods and darknesses to the
expanses expansiveness of this life and
the expansiveness of the next so this is
religion functional religion you know we
ask a lot allow us to get back to that
i mean but these three steps it's a 100
percent hit like this is how the
religion is designed to transform to
regulate bring about the sort of
transformation within the heart of the
human human being imam derek thank you
so much for being with us here on the
dean's show
god is the greatest allah is the
greatest
and inshallah this can be a benefit for
everyone here and everyone that's not
here that's watching us
out there but the potential millions
inshallah this could be your motivations
to people to think deeper what's the
purpose of life why am i here
they can actually read the quran and get
it for free at the deanshow.com get your
copy today and call us if you have any
other questions 1-800-662-4752
and we'll see you next time here on the
dean's show thank you to everybody here
at the pompano masjid
thank you very much may allah bless you
bless this community and one last time
peace be with you assalamu alaikum